i think that people should have hobbies
i think as you said every person in the
world probably have at least two things
that are that are interesting about
probably more but a lot of people are
not really
uh following up on that so
first i would say follow up on your
passion
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright xl j impact
leap google for startups and hippo and
in media partnership with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders this
episode is all about the combining of
passion professionalism a work-life
balance if that exists
and how to pursue what one really wants
to pursue
meet aganerel senior high tech leader by
day and best-selling author by night
again is the country manager of f5 in
israel greece and cyprus and a respected
author whose books have reached the top
of the bestseller list alan published
his first novel foretelling yesterday in
2011 by idiot
and last year he has published a second
novel the human element by kinetizon
also known as a planned kill
his writing work is influenced and
driven by the changes and experiences in
his career path on the other hand he
brings the creative world into his role
in management strategies as well as to
the content worlds in which he operates
i have to say that you probably have the
nicest work background that i have seen
yet
it's it's at the point where somebody
should make a zoom back zoom background
with whatever you have and then sell
that to others to have as a virtual
background it's so nice
oh thank you so first i'll tell my wife
so this is the one of the benefits of um
actually being married to an interior
designer
there you go i had no idea
so she designs everything and by the way
what you just said so at least three or
four engineers in my team actually
generated the virtual background from
this background
and they're even going to meetings with
myself included and they're just putting
this in virtual background as their
background as well so i love that
yeah that's what it works as a virtual
background
i love it you see this is how i'm
getting people who are listening and on
on spotify to come in and check it out
on video it's it's through the no no i'm
kidding of course
one of the most fascinating pieces of
your background
is sort of this multidisciplinary nature
and you told me one thing that that
stuck with me that will be the theme of
this conversation right before we
started which is that
you would not be able to give up either
parts of your life sort of the creative
piece and the more professional piece
which which i found very interesting and
obviously you'll tie it in much nicer
than i can but but i found that very
inspiring already so so again you know
get us started tell me a little bit
about sort of who you are what do you do
and and how and a little bit about your
career journey
okay so so indeed so i have two
disciplines that i wouldn't i wouldn't
have let go any of the going
i'll talk about my careers for
uh for a minute and then i'm going to
talk about the writing and how
everything
works together for me so
in terms of my career so i was writing
code in the
in the army afterwards uh i joined a an
integration company as a as a
information security technical engineer
and throughout my career most of my
roles until i joined cisco and even
within cisco
or on the technical side of things a
pre-cell engineer
working developing developing solutions
developing architectures that's what i
like so i like technology i love
technology and everything that i do is
based on my love towards technology and
building solutions with um customers
partners with people
um later on what i've done is actually
switched more to the business side of
thing to more of a sort of a gm or a
country manager role so within cisco it
was managing the private sector later on
within f5 what i do for the last three
years
is actually the country manager for uh
for israel for priests cyprus the
palestinian palestinian authority
as well which is also interesting and
the relationships that were building
towards um a biventing business together
um with the palestinian authority
and the other
discipline that you talked about is
actually writing so
my hobby is writing books i've published
two
best-selling novels the first one was in
yet
idiot books
defeated and uh it's a thriller um and
the other book is also a thriller but
what led me to actually writing the
first book
was um i started a startup company that
i formed uh right after um
right after the the army uh with a
partner and a very close friend of mine
and this so i won't i won't tell the
entire story because we only have 20
minutes but i will say that
um it ended badly and when it ended i
had two options either i pursued some
sort of legal action or and i decided
against
uh the other alternative was to sit in
front of a blank page and start started
writing
so that's what i did and it took me 49
days to put in writing my experience
which later on five years later and um
various iterations and and
uh it turned into 500 pages completely
wow
novel
and it was a bestseller best-selling
um well i'm a bit biased but it was a
good one and then my second book was
just chuck published uh a year ago in
qnetic another publishing house um in
israel
and
and again
the combination of both so i love
technology and i i don't want to let
this one go and i love writing so i need
both
in my life because i think they
complement each other
incredible i i love the i love that
approach and i'm sure that that story of
writing that first book deserves a whole
episode on its own tell me a little bit
about
you know one life having sort of two
two separate lives in one and they're
they're intertwined in one way but i'm
sure that
the way you interact with each of these
sub lives is quite different
mentally emotionally you know um
spiritually if you if one will entertain
that
how do you balance and and how how are
they different those two aspects of your
life
where they're different and they're not
different so they're interwined as as
you said so
technological piece of so first both of
my books have some sort of a technology
piece in them so the first book was a
startup company of young people from tel
aviv building uh
which are building a startup company and
then things go wrong because it's a
thriller
and then the other the second book which
just came out a year ago
it's cosmetics company but the
technological cosmetics company so it's
always technology in the center in the
background
of what i'm writing
and
and my actual um
daily
daily work i actually um what i do is i
tell stories i tell stories in
conventions and presentations and my
team meetings and my
um in my strategy meetings because
everything is a story everything we do
is a story uh whether it's technology or
some sort of uh
analogy that we're bringing from um um
from either aspect into into what we do
in our daily lives then makes things
much more interesting so i would say
these two things are interwined you know
technology with writing and
um
and writing with technology and you
cannot really separate the two the two
live
together what what in how how do you
find joy
in this different thing how do they how
do they fulfill you maybe differently is
what i'm interested in where do you find
that that inner inner fulfillment
well you know writing
that's a good one but you know the
writing is
is extremely lonely
when i write i find myself um
locking the door to my room i'm not
seeing my kids i'm not seeing my wife
i'm not even leaving lunch so i'm just
i'm staying in my room starting seven or
eight am
12 hours straight i'm not going out i'm
just writing i have a words quota that i
need to fulfill
and
very very lonely
then on the other side um technology on
business you're always interacting
very trying to interact with uh with
people with with companies with uh with
customers with partners so you're always
um in some sort of interactions so it's
not lonely the opposite of lonely and
sometimes i want to be alone with
yourselves
so um
i think that this is the way that i
explain to myself when i need both
pieces the writing the creation the
creativity being alone creating and then
the other piece of always interacting
always um
uh be part of some sort of a social
um a social circle that does something
um so
i hope this sensor is what you
well it definitely does but but it begs
the next question which is how do you
know what to do when one aspect that you
mentioned is a quota right you have a
responsibility
to your job and you have a
responsibility to the other job whether
it's you know to kinetic or to the
author to yourself you set goals
creative work and professional work they
both require a lot of discipline and to
do either of them very well i assume
and a little bit from my own experience
as well you need to come into it with a
clear mind i don't think you could get
many words down on a paper if you just
force yourself to sit down you kind of
need to be in somewhat of an enabling
mind state
how do you
you know put that into the whole
equation
of what to do when and how much
you cannot write a book
while actually
doing your daily job or daily routine
you do have to disconnect
clear your mind and only write but
so if i'm like an analogy here would be
writing a book is the marathon
but the actual writing piece
the sprint because writing the book
could take two or three weeks if you're
extremely disciplined
so i'm gonna take on
a vacation for two weeks i'm going to
work for 14 days straight i'm gonna do
10 000 awards 10 000 words a day
wow i'm gonna finish the novel within
two weeks i'm gonna come well prepared
for this so i'm gonna distract structure
i'm gonna have a skeleton for uh for the
book
um but when i'm when i'm writing it it's
gonna be without any um interference
it's gonna be um like sprint like a
really short sprint
but then the problem is
it's not done it's not finished i need
it right to let this go to give this to
people that doesn't know me that will
read it and give me feedback and this
process can take years
this is a marathon because now you can
do your daily work because you're gonna
you gotta forget about the book you're
gonna take at least two or three months
until people give your feedback until
you gather feedback and you gather your
thoughts around what what you want out
what you want to do in the book meantime
you're not really doing anything that
has to do with the book and then the
other when you're starting to edit uh to
edit the books and make changes you can
do it overnight we can do it in the
mornings like for you 4am doesn't sound
great but but but it works and 4 a.m
until 7 00 a.m or from over the weekend
um and then you can finish the book
while you're actually you're actually
working and it doesn't interfere with
anything
but the whitey piece itself
it needs to be a
sprint and you need two or three weeds
to
to complete the entire book
i want to go up in the air a little bit
about 30 000 feet and extrapolate a
little bit from from what we're talking
about because for you you're talking
about sort of being a technological
leader at the same while writing books
but i think it speaks to a more great to
a greater trend
where you know we're growing up in a
world that is much more
multidisciplinary we have many more
opportunities and and we discover
passions and excitement
right brain left brain middle brain back
brain that you know that it's very
unlikely that one
one element in our life will satisfy all
of our needs and desires so you've sort
of you know where we're talking here is
if it's almost this contrarian approach
that you're taking to life having these
two big
things that you're excited about i can
only imagine that most people in the
world can get excited about at least two
things and now it's a question of you
know whether to pursue it or and to take
on this challenge of being able to
balance these different things how have
you thought about you know what this may
mean you know for different people
around you or
different trends around the world
yeah i think that people should have
hobbies i think as you said every person
in the world probably have at least two
things
that are that are interesting about
probably more but a lot of people are
not really
following up on that so
first i would say follow up on your
passion
so you need to love what you're doing i
don't know you're doing um podcasts or
you're investing i'm finished right
you're enjoying
what you do
i'm having fun right now i do cyber
security for one of the greatest
companies in the world so i they love it
and if you're not
into what you're actually doing
throughout 10 or whatever hours
every day then you should probably
switch switch roles rich jobs
but love what you do but then find
yourself a hobby ma'am a hobby that will
actually fulfill you oh you know
i love martial arts and i was into
fencing then i had a band i didn't
really think you were even
national champion at 13 if i remember
correctly and fencing again
championship and in israel it was a very
long time ago but um yeah i can hold the
sword that's work
for sure um i had a band but i so i was
singing in the band but i really don't
know how to do i'm not singing very well
and i'm not playing very well but it was
fun it was good
um
and i enjoyed it and i think it's the
same with writing and without a hobby so
i think that each person should have
this hobby or
and and and you know we're living here
in
in israel and everything and sometimes
it's very very stress we're working very
very hard and working around the clock
and sometimes we're forgetting to relax
a bit to put everything aside and do
something very really really passionate
about
so i would say um yes every person can
definitely find this passion and every
person should also follow this passion
and and find a framework
to make it work okay so you like
something make it work you know how to
make it work nobody else knows how to
make it work but the person will know
how to make this
passion work within the daily routine
right i think also probably an
interesting question that is how to even
begin by asking these questions and how
to
you know ponder through them in a
structured way or a framework way which
then actually allows you to go and do
that and how do you communicate
those decisions to the world whether it
be your family i'm sure that it's not a
trivial thing for you to come to your
wife and say one day listen i'm going to
write a book
and i'm going to take on a second
full-time job and it's gonna have
implications but it'll make me a much
happier person i can only i don't know
if that's how the conversation went on
your side
well i'm i'm lucky here so actually
the only reason
which i actually got to publish in this
book was my wife because she was an
integral part of the ideation process uh
really what we're gonna write about um
and then when i wrote the book there
were so many problems with with the with
the draft so we just worked together for
days on solving these issues and always
the best solutions actually come from
her not for me
so now on this aspect i'm i'm a lucky
person but yeah sometimes it's um it
consumes a lot of your time you know
you're sitting in a room for hours upon
hours you're writing or you're working
okay i've been
on
being a country manager for a
significant operation
are you working on many many hours so it
takes a toll but you need a partner that
will
believe in you that will
um
that will go to this marathon with you
but you also need to
remember that your partner has their own
passions
and you have to make sure that you're
supporting their own passions
as well
so
i'm making sure to always remember that
i need to support these passions and i
love her passions as well so it's easy
for me
um but it doesn't work um
it's it only works if both people care
about what the other person want to do
right and i guess it's about
it it's about caring for how for how to
help the other person reach their own
fulfillment so that they are fulfilled
in their day to day and then they can
help you become fulfilled yourself in
the day to day right
i'll give you a small example so my wife
i'd love that interior designer for the
last five years
uh before that
she worked in retail she had like 70
employees in retail and one day she came
to me and she said i don't want to do
this any
i love design i love graphic design i
love designing houses i wanna
i wanna change i wanna make change
and she actually
did that she went studying first few
years um
and she changed her life she changed our
lives and now she has a successful
interior designing the business she
designs the most beautiful
houses or you're seeing this uh
zoom background um
as well so it actually worked here both
ways so they're both supporting each
other and i think that if you don't have
this
support system in place and if you're
not willing to also support the other
person
then um
first of all that's inspiring and i and
i can't help but notice that i i heard a
tiny bit of kids in the background and
so this begs
the the most important question i guess
how do you take you know what you've
learned about yourself about your wife
and about sort of this reaching personal
fulfillment through
through structure framework and doing
and then it's not just about you know
the hobbies that you're mentioning
they're not sort of what people may
consider time wasters these are actually
really really interesting pieces of your
life that you're developing over time
that you're identifying that these are
cornerstone pieces of who you are as
people and and so they're very valuable
how how are you thinking through that as
a as a father as a parent to to your
kids as they grow up into a world where
there are structures there's
non-structural things how do you think
through that
that's a that's a deep philosophic
question uh because you know it's um so
i'm first i'm trying not to put too much
pressure on them
but um it's not easy and um
i think that i'm trying to do the things
that i like with them if they like it as
well just give you a small example so
we're actually writing short stories
together so if my son has an idea he's
10 years old he's very noisy yeah you
might be hearing him from time to time
here
um
so we had an idea so he just wrote a
book whatever about some some weird
turtle that goes to and does you know
and meet friends and whatever
um see just there you know we're
mimicking what i love
and doing this with with them or we're
taking the guitar
so honestly the guitar is here there's a
beautiful background but i'm not really
playing it it's probably out of tune um
i am playing it when
when they go to sleep and i have uh the
mood to play with them
yeah so
you do
you know you love music so you do music
with your kids you do you love writing
so you're trying to writing to write
with your kids you have technology so
you bring your kids to your
um
to your team meetings to your department
meetings to the conventions that you're
so
both of my kids were i had front row
seats in one of the conventions that i
had uh
a couple of years ago they just study in
the crowd and uh two and a half years
ago and they and they listened and i
said that's awesome you know
you're making what you're doing and
making part of the entire uh family with
your
um with your spouse with your
your kids um you're trying to have fun
as a family
thank you so much for for this time and
for this uh
energon and for the insights this is why
i do this show so thank you very very
much i wish you best of luck
with with the novel that was published a
year ago i'm i'm wish i i'm excited for
myself
as i'm definitely going to go and buy
and read it and knowing sort of a little
bit about the progress that you went
through as you're writing it and i and i
can only imagine that different awesome
things you and your wife will do in the
future so thank you again for the
inspiring words for the more more so
even inspiring thought process about
you know life our own professions and
and how do we find structure and
framework for the different things we
love to do
so again thank you very much
thank you so much mikhail and enjoy it
very very much and i'm waiting looking
forward for your feedback about the
novels 100 100 percent
[Music]